und jetzt raten sie doch mal wer heute
da ist nah kommen sie nie drauf das
schönste zweig publikum der welt meine
damen und herren ist hier
ja
genesen
gelaufen
noch
ich neige nicht zum schreiben aber ganz
ehrlich für mich seid ihr jetzt schon
das beste publikum das für die letzten
anderthalb jahren wirklich
und sie kommen genau rechtzeitig und
zwar zur geburt der ampel rot gelb grüne
rauch über berlin hb muss ampel ja ja
haben sie sicher verfolgt heute ab
nächster woche schon
koalitionsverhandlungen das ist rekord
so was steht in dem heute
veröffentlichten ampel plan da steht
mindestlohn 12 euro schuldenbremse
bleibt investiert wird trotzdem wird
schon
klimaschädliche subventionen werden
hoffentlich gestrichen dafür gibt es
kein tempolimit und ein kohleausstieg
schon 2030 wird sagen wir mal angestrebt
jetzt kann also auch mal inhalte durch
und die medien haben endlich etwas
substanzielles zu berichten heute morgen
war beginn der gespräche dachte ich noch
kurz die sonne vom roten teppich in
cannes da ist er wird mal winfried
kretschmann von mir sehen annalena
baerbock jetzt geht er übrigens rein ins
gebäude das tut sich jetzt
dass karin göring-eckardt sie mir doch
robert habeck sagt sie was sagt sie
nichts holt sie wieder ein schokoriegel
raus
nicht christian winter auf jeden fall
sollte
da ist christian lindner ich glaube sie
sucht ihre macht da hatten richtig da
hast du vollkommen recht gehabt das hat
aber so ausgesehen als wenn sie wirklich
was sagen würde aber an der werburg hat
nichts gesagt ich drehe durch annalena
baerbock hat nichts gesagt aber sie
trägt eine freche übergangsjacke aus
nachhaltiger alpakawolle
dafür 300 schweine journalist am teppich
robert habeck sagt zitat die ampel darf
nicht scheitern ja könnte ja rein
theoretisch noch passieren wegen der
neuen vertraulichkeit wissen wir gar
nicht wie heftig die sich hinter den
kulissen streiten auch heute wurde
wieder sehr viel über aufbruch und
modernisierung geredet wer ist denn
gegen modernisierung ich habe mir den
satz lass das deutsche internet man
genau so wie es ist
denen hört man eher selten so jetzt
kriegen wir endlich butter bei die
fische stadt phrasen manche klang ja
fast schon verstören privat das heißt es
braucht ein vertrauens raum der ist den
partnern ermöglicht dinge mal zu
probieren der fantasie sozusagen zu
folgen
mit den partnern plural fantasievoll
dinge probieren warum möchte ich
plötzlich duschen egal was man ganz
ernst das jetzt was man loben muss diese
neuen ampel ideen die heute rausgekommen
sind reichen endlich mal weiter als bis
zur nächsten wahl längerfristig gedacht
aber egal wer am ende finanzminister
wird einige davon von diesen ideen
werden wohl noch am geld scheitern ja
denn davon haben wir ich mir so viel
wenn die groko wir erinnern uns wenn die
groko sich gestritten hatten also mütter
rente oder rente mit 63 war die lösung
scheiß drauf wir machen beides das geht
so nicht mehr die ganzen ausgaben
wünsche erfüllen mit schuldenbremse und
ohne steuererhöhung um zu glauben dass
das funktioniert muss man schon sehr
viel legalisiert das cannabis rauchen
ja zuletzt wurde schon über schatten
oder nebenhaushalte geredet hier lindner
noch kurz vor der wahl also kommt der
vorschlag des potentiellen
finanzministers robert habeck lasst uns
nicht mehr von schulden sprechen sondern
von krediten
nichts geht über ein natürliches lachen
und und koalieren koalieren geht nicht
ohne kompromisse
tatsächlich müssen wir bei einigen
themen als bürger beten dass sich die
parteien nicht zu 100 prozent
durchsetzen die fdp zum beispiel mit
ihren steuerplänen die eins zu eins
umsetzung könnte den staat wirklich
absurd viel geld kosten trotzdem gilt
christian lender immer noch als großer
finanzexperte wie geht das kann man
jetzt lernen die christian lindner
master glas wie heißt man 90
milliardenloch in den bundeshaushalt
einer der besten volkswirte der welt
hatte leider keine zeit deswegen erklärt
christian lindner was passiert wenn man
steuern senkt und trotzdem investiert
dann sind 90 milliarden hildes jahr weg
nicht mehr da an einem besseren ort aber
warum kennt sich dieses finanzgenie so
verdammt gut mit geld aus ihre
freundliche maske die mich heute morgen
vorbereitet hat sagte ich sei ja
steinbock und damit könnte ich ja gut
mit geld genau qualifikation steinbock
und nächste woche lernen wir von
anna-lena wie man einen lebenslauf
frisiert denn sie ist sternzeichen
baerbock
[Musik]
seehofer
die mastercard ja das ist
totaler beschiss der kurs so was er
kenne ich als wieder sofort
man könnt ihr mal ganz verrückt gedacht
man könnte ja kleine und mittlere
einkommen entlasten aber dafür den
spitzensteuersatz erhöhen wird nicht
passieren wissen wir seit heute meine
alle müssen sich doch bewegen gilt
übrigens auch für die spd die sozen
sagen kategorisch mit uns keine erhöhung
des renteneintrittsalters punkt ja
kompromissvorschlag wer erst mit 67 in
rente will fängt dafür früher an zu
arbeiten
ja warum nicht
ja wirklich jetzt ich habe noch keinen
siebenjährigen über rückenschmerzen
klagen
in diesem jahr muss der staat 106
milliarden steuer kohle bei der rente zu
schießen das ist ein fünftel des
bundeshaushalts und das wird in den
nächsten jahren ohne echte reform
deutlich mehr warum wegen der ganzen
boomer in rente gehen
ja immer mehr geld bedeutet das für
rentner das dann natürlich für
zukunftsthemen wie bildung oder
digitalisierung fehlt es ist so ich
dachte das wäre eine zukunfts koalition
rodinger dort mal auf die spd zu dissen
die macht echt viel für uns junge leute
alle anderen parteien die pfleger
trensch
spd zukunftspolitik für leute die gar
nicht mehr so viel zukunft haben
deswegen wollen sie sorgt beim 60
zuletzt
deshalb
deshalb haben die so zu nehmen fast alle
wahlkreise gewonnen immerhin immerhin
will die ampel am einstieg in einen
staatlichen renten fonds arbeiten hat
man heute gelesen apropos leute die nur
noch wenig zukunft haben die cdu ist
die cdu ist diese woche in einer umfrage
jetzt wird's bitter unter die 20 prozent
marke gerutscht
und 20 wenn das so weiter geht können
sie das adenauer haus direkt
untervermieten
es passt doch super
ja das hat
nein
das passt schon gut zusammen die gehen
auch nicht besser mit ihrem personal
open bei der cdu stimmt so langsam die
letzte hoffnung auf jamaika der zug ist
abgefahren
super metapher findet auch dieser
fdp-abgeordnete und ja übertreibt es
dann ein wenig der ampel zurollt die
union war nicht abfahrbereite und dann
sind wir an den zug eingestiegen stärker
bereit war wehr setze ich voraus des
zuges beim union zu kann sich eben noch
lokführer und schaffner und sonstiges
personal
teilt der spd zug und der unions zug her
da standen zwei züge der der ampel zug
aus dem bahnhof geplant sind den zug
eingestiegen werden dann am bahnhof ein
neuer zug steht kann man da ein stein
grüne und fdp wollte losfahren und wer
weiß vielleicht steigen grünen und fdp
irgendwo aus dem spd zog wieder mal
ausgang nicht jetzt auch mal den zug aus
dem bahnhof heraus bringen
die nächste zug metapher verspätet sich
um hoffentlich 60 minuten so wie geht es
jetzt weiter mit der völlig entgleisten
union ende des monats sollen die
kreisvorsitzenden überlegen wie
basisdemokratisch die neue parteiführung
bestimmt wird das heißt die diskutieren
schon wieder nur über köpfe ja statt
sich endlich mal zu überlegen was sie
eigentlich sein wollen was ist heute
noch konservativ hier mal eine
klassische antwort mit überraschender
schluss beamte ich glaube uns als cdu
tragen ja grundüberzeugung die auch in
der zukunft nach wie vor modern sein
können und müssen aus dem christlichen
menschenbild heraus etwa das
leistungsprinzip
christliche werte wie das
andererseits jesus hat sogar noch nach
seinem tod weiter gearbeitet das ist
also ein stück mehr leistung für die
bürger dar
jesus würde heute fdp wählen natürlich
denn wie heißt es im dritten gebot du
sollst nicht herzen man kann es drehen
man kann es drehen und wenden wie man
will die union braucht einen neuanfang
und stellen sich vor da liegt die csu
die kleine schwester eindeutig vor ich
gehe sogar so weit zu behaupten bei der
csu hat gerade von ihnen unbemerkt eine
revolution stattgefunden
sie haben ganz richtig gehört eine
revolution in bayern und zwar sagt die
junge union dort den offenen aufstand
gegen markus söder ist am letzten
wochenende passiert wir schalten wir
live in die münchner innenstadt zu
unserem reporter albrecht humboldt
albrecht bringen wir uns nochmal auf den
stand oliver sie sehen es vielleicht
hinter mir verstärkte polizeipräsenz und
ein bataillon gebirgsjäger sicher zur
stunde sodass staatskanzlei kein wunder
nach den ereignissen des letzten
wochenendes auf dem parteitag der jungen
union in deggendorf mit stargast markus
söder beantragen durchgedrehte csu
kinder die wunderbaren worte markus und
söder aus einem antrag zu streichen da
hätte stehen sollen unser zugpferd
markus söder und dann geht da so ein
bengel ans mikrofon und sagt es kann
nicht sein dass wir alles nur auf eine
person zu schneiden es funktioniert
einfach nicht mehr wir sind keine ein
mann partei wir sind die csu es ist
keine ein mann partei ja was denn sonst
wäre die kommune wo alle menschen gleich
viel wert sind ich vermute das war
subtile kritik der parteijugend an herrn
söder das ego trip der ganzen letzten
monate ja und ich vermute diese trotz
klagen müssten mal ordentlich verzinst
werden
immerhin der versammlungsleiter hat noch
versucht den eklat zu verhindern mit
einer kompromiss formulierung stadt zug
fährt söder
zb mit markus söder oder den
staatsminister
da schreibt einer lauten nein
zu meiner zeit kannten wir das wort gar
nicht wir sind ja damals in die junge
union eingetreten weil wir eben nicht
aufmüpfig waren gut und natürlich weil
uns frauen nicht mal mit der kneifzange
angefasst hätten aber das ist ja hier
nicht der punkt ja was ist dann der
punkt der punkt ist man kann sich nicht
einfach als parteijugend gegen den
großen vorsitzenden auflehnen ok zuerst
dachte ich noch kommt egal ein sohn
drogensüchtiger illner stellten an
dieser antrag kommt ähnlich durch aber
dann dann schließlich die abstimmung und
wir wissen was rauskommt herzrisiko
die klatschen auch noch und dann dürfen
die danach unbehelligt den saal
verlassen klar man hat sich alle namen
aufgeschrieben aber der schaden der
schaden ist angerichtet
was sollen die leute jetzt in bayern
denken wieso ist es doch ganz schön dass
da auch mal eine eigene meinung
vertreten wird ach ja was kommt als
nächstes ziehen hier mitglieder der
jungen union mit direkter faust durch
münchen und schreiben nieder mit dem
regime oder was
die herren wachtmeister
missverständnis
ich habe gerade fiktive mitglieder der
jungen union lediglich zitiert
ich würde ja niemals ich bin ja selber
großer fan vom silbersee sieben fan der
ersten stunde sitzen
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
hast du scheiße fährt haye